November 22nd 1963 is a point in history
that has arguably shaped all of modern
society it's the day when the world was
shaken and the fictional might of the
most powerful man in the world was
proven a falsehood is the day when the
President of the United States was
murdered in front of the entire world it
was considered the day television was no
longer in its adolescence due to the
tragic and shocking event being covered
live on news it all culminated when the
assassin Lee Harvey Oswald was himself
assassinated on live TV while being
transferred to a different police
station the event had an effect on the
entire world from that point on life
would never be as vivaciously serene as
it had been during the previous decade
some might say the American Dream died
that day
the assassination itself has been
subject to numerous conspiracy theories
and an absurd amount of speculation
throughout the years since that fateful
day but today we will tell you the truth
what really happened as well as who
really killed John F Kennedy
it all started when President John F
Kennedy and his wife Jacqueline made a
trip to Dallas Texas to hold a meeting
to build peace between Ralph Yarborough
and John Connally
however peace was never an option as
Kennedy was a controversial leader and
made several powerful enemies during his
tenure as the first president with the
x-gene the motorcade route was announced
four days prior giving the true assassin
of Kennedy plenty of time to plan the
attack that would play out as the
vehicles past the grassy knoll in a
parade like convoy the president's
ruthless vehicle was left helpless and
vulnerable at the time of 12:30 p.m.
what history is largely neglected to
inform us is just how many shooters were
involved and who was holding those
rifles that ended America's vision of
safety for many decades to come Lee
Harvey Oswald is one of the most notable
perpetrators of the crime but did he act
alone in a sense he was assisted by
powers far greater than one could
imagine the fatal shooting was filmed on
that day by onlooker Abraham Zapruder it
was very much oblivious that day to what
was happening mere feet behind him as
known vigilante Edward Blake fired a
shot that hit Kennedy directly in the
head causing his brain to splinter
backwards and forcing skull fragments
onto the rear of the vehicle Edward
Blake is a former covert government
operative that later served in Vietnam
but was discharged due to his violent
tendencies and erratic behavior during
missions Blake was positioned behind
Zapruder with the intention to shoot at
him at the event due to a brief
altercation they had at a bar the
previous night but on the day in
question Blake was still heavily niibori
too due to the excessive recreational
drinking that morning and missed his
shot hitting Kennedy instead by pure
mistake upon realizing this accident
Blake then lowers his rifle and begins
to pack his belongings being so
nonplussed by this experience that he
never stopped smoking his Cuban cigar a
fine piece of irony given Kennedy's
history however Edward Blake is far from
the only second shooter the second
second shooter is a man by the name of
James Buchanan bars
James was a member of the US Army
serving multiple tours in World War two
who is pronounced m.i.a before he could
be properly discharged although he was
thought to be dead it is now clear he
has ties to some sort of Soviet
sympathizing terrorist organization
Barnes was spotted on a water tower in
Irving Texas
he is photographed here readying his
rifle of an unknown calibre
he took his shot at 12:27 p.m. this was
also a fatal blow you may be wondering
just how many suspects were involved the
assassination was also subject to
multiple heroic yet ultimately futile
attempts at being prevented as stated
before Kennedy was the first
presidential elect to be born with the X
gene making him a prime target for
recruitment and collusion by the wanted
mutant terrorists Erik Lehnsherr also
known as max Eisenhart also known as
Magnus also known as the leader of the
terrorist cell the Brotherhood of
mutants also known as the Brotherhood of
Evil Mutants also known as the
Brotherhood being a sympathizer with
Kennedy's plight as a mutated American
he attempted to stop Lee Harvey Oswald's
second shot but was immediately tackled
by a Secret Service agent causing his
magnetic effect over the bullet to
behave sporadically and curving the
bullets path in an odd pattern that
would hit Kennedy and Governor John
Connally
thus resulting in the magic or bent
bullet Theory linter was placed in
protective custody until his prison
break in 1973 his current whereabouts
are unknown
flincher story is a tragic one as he was
one of the only men who attempted to do
the right thing that day and yet the
American people's mutant bias was so
strong at the time that he was
immediately believed to be one of the
assassins he was tackled to the ground
despite being about four feet away from
another of the second gunman the man
known as the ultimate Red Skull who had
fired from the grassy knoll with a
silenced pistol at Kennedy's head this
was a fatal shot the Secret Service had
seen him earlier but assumed he was
merely an American veteran with a slight
facial deformity given too
combat further sealing kennedy's demise
was the bullet fired from the fifth
floor of the Book Depository by none
other than Alex Mason former CIA
operative and Russian sleeper agent who
was carrying out his mind controlled
programming that was given to him in the
four Kuta gulag
by an inmate named victor Rezanov this
bullet slightly grazed Kennedy's upper
ear before ricocheting off the pavement
causing debris to strike The Spectator
by the name of James T tape on the cheek
this is not a fatal shot the mark from
the bullet has never been found due to
the bullet completely disintegrating
into the asphalt the weather of the next
few days along with the traffic and
street sweepers cover up the impact
turned in the crater into nothing but a
small dimple in the road the conspiracy
deepens as we investigate one of the
less famous assassins involved in the
murder the obscure Lee Harvey Oswald is
also speculated by many to have had at
least some input on the death of JFK
Oswald was an ex-marine Sharpshooter for
the US military who had known ties to
the Soviet Communist Party as well as a
burning hatred for the American
government however Oswald was not always
in control of his actions as over the
last several years leading up to that
fateful day his body was controlled at
random intervals by the quantum leap in
consciousness of dr. Samuel Beckett a
physicist whose mind would switch places
with strangers throughout history a
strange affliction yet on the day of the
assassination
Oswald's personality became more
dominant in the body of in Beckett's
forcing the otherwise kind-hearted
scientist to nearly commit the act
himself at the last minute before firing
his three shots Beckett was interrupted
by this man
James Franco the famed Hollywood actor
was researching for a college project by
traveling to the year 1963 in order to
stop Oswald's attempt on Kennedy's life
in altering the timeline Beckett's
personality was able to quantum leap
into the body of Secret Service agent
Clint Hill just before Oswald finally
took his shots Franco and his girlfriend
at the time Sadie
then began a physical altercation with
Oswald that ended with Franco
incapacitating the sniper with his own
rifle before the police were able to
apprehend him Oswald's second shot as
stated previously was nearly deflected
by Erik Lehnsherr before the Secret
Service became involved his third made
contact tam Beckett's consciousness did
not seal enter as a threat due to his
original time period remute and
Americans were more accepted by the
general public and instead opted to jump
in the way of Oswald Mason shots that
would have hit Kennedy's wife Jacqueline
unbeknownst to Beckett as he possessed
the body of Clint Hill Jacqueline
Kennedy was switched out earlier that
day with a body double a woman by the
name of Alison Hargreaves who had spoken
directly to Kennedy moments before the
chaos using her reality manipulation
powers to cause his head to explode in
addition to the explosion caused by the
impact of the rifle and pistol shots had
Sam Beckett in the body of Clint Hill
not left in the way of Hargreaves to
protect her Kennedy's head would have
been slightly easier to identify using
cutting-edge modern technology on the
exhumed body of Kennedy researchers have
discovered this was actually the body of
none other than one Josef Fitzgerald a
historian from the year 21 72 after
confirming his name and occupation we
also learned that he had prevented John
Kennedy's death that day in an
alternative timeline after finding what
he had done changed the future to an
assured nuclear war he disclosed
confidential temporal information to the
now very much alive president then being
made aware of the effect his survival
had on the rest of the world John agreed
to travel through time to correct the
future rather than allowing his ancestor
to die an unnecessary death Joseph
devised a plan
Joseph Fitzgerald swapped places with
Kennedy just before the intense multi
impact had
his skull due to the sheer amount of
rounds and/or reality altering powers
that it supposedly caused Kennedy's
demise
the ballistics forensics had revealed
that all of these rounds collided with
each other to the point of
disintegration leaving only two
fragments behind James Franco was
arrested at the scene in question for
his involvement in order to preserve the
timeline where Kennedy was believed dead
he received a phone call from a cleverly
devised life model decoy provided by the
CIA and one Nicholas J fury thanking him
for saving the president's life so he
would get back to his original timeline
falsely believing he prevented the
Vietnam war to get an A in his physics
class he failed his final era clincher
James Barnes Alex Mason and the ultimate
Red Skull are still at large
Edward Blake unfortunately passed away
due to an accident in his New York
apartment in the mid-80s respected
private investigator Walter Kovacs
suspects foul play Lee Harvey Oswald
passed away due to an accident involving
dramatic irony a few days later it was
our pleasure to bring these facts and
truths to light and finally close the
book on this age-old mystery who exactly
filmed all of these events is however
still up for speculation and is a source
of heated contention and debate about an
our own team of researchers thankfully
the real John F Kennedy survived the
ordeal with minor injuries and has gone
on to teach at the University of Harvard
in the year 21 72
you